here on fox but first we're going to
head south for just a minute by every
objective
measure cases deaths hospitalizations
the state of florida has handled the
coronavirus
much more effectively than states than
new york specifically new york and new
jersey
and they've done it without destroying
every small business in the state and
that's why those states are emptying out
and moving to florida
florida by the way is leading new york
in vaccine distribution as well
and at the same time as we just noted
people
are leaving those two states and moving
to the state of florida
which by the way is controlled by a
republican and maybe that's why cnn is
enraged
by all of this they don't want you to
know that chris cuomo's brother is
running new york
so instead they attack the state of
florida and that's why this week on
monday which would be let's see
yesterday
one of cnn's activists posing as a
reporter went after the governor of
florida to give this little speech
you'll hear directly from the governor
of florida in just a minute but first
fox tampa bay chief political reporter
craig patrick is following this exchange
for us and the broader story he joins us
tonight hey craig
hi there tucker how are you great thank
you
so the the state of florida does does
seem like
it's been the focus of a lot of media
hostility recently have you noticed
that well certainly the governor's faced
a lot of tough questions with respect to
the most recent controversies there have
been long waits in florida for vaccines
that's true
there have been phone lines that have
been overwhelmed and people frustrated
and complaining we're hearing a lot of
that but
one of the biggest reasons for that is
that the governor has placed a priority
on moving all senior citizens 65 and
over to the front of the line there are
4.3 million seniors in the state of
florida
a byproduct of doing that will in fact
be
long waits at the beginning stages of
distributing vaccines but
as the governor sees it he's saying look
the choice is
uh say inoculating someone in their 20s
versus someone who is a senior citizen
he's looking at case fatality rates
those more likely to come become
seriously ill or uh or in some cases die
and he's thinking in the interest of
saving lives
that's the direction he's going to go
and there also yes has been controversy
a lot of us have seen the video of
senior citizens camped out
overnight outside of a hospital but the
governor has also said
we're in the early stages and he is
monitoring
how well each hospital is doing and that
future shipments of vaccines the doses
will wind up
going to the hospitals that do the
better job
of distributing those vaccines
do do you have tape of the exchange
between the governor and the cnn
reporter today
ready to roll i think i don't know if i
have seen it okay
if i i don't know we yeah we're gonna i
want to roll it right now for our
audience just to get some
sense of the politics that have been
intruded on this
here's what happened watch this what has
gone wrong with the rollout of the
vaccine that we've seen
phone lines jammed websites crashed a
lot of demand i mean i think at the end
of the day
excuse me excuse me if i could finish my
you just said what has gone wrong so i'm
answering the question if i could
complete the question though
so are you going to give a speech are
you going to answer ask a question we've
seen websites crash
and also senior citizens waiting
overnight for the vaccine where was that
at
we've seen it in duvall broward orange
and
why was there a big line did you did you
investigate why
could you tell us because we we
distributed vaccine
to hospitals and in the hospital said
first come first serve if you show up
we'll do it
yeah tucker the governor is yeah he's
recognizing that there are issues but
you know what there are issues all
across the country and the governor
keeps saying he's making adjustments he
made adjustments today
by moving doses to public supermarkets
to get
it more available to people where they
live the same goes for selecting
churches converting
a testing centers into vaccination
centers it takes steps in time among
other things he doesn't know the precise
amounts that are coming in
week by week until just a few days
before they arrive
craig i appreciate it thanks so much for
joining us today
we're now joined by the governor of
florida ron desantis governor thanks so
much
for coming on i i almost never provide a
forum for politicians and politicians to
defend themselves or defend them
but i just can't help but notice that as
the entire northeast moves to your state
and as the numbers become
clear that florida has managed this this
pandemic
far better than any northeastern state
that you're coming under all this
media criticism why do you think that is
well tucker look i am totally willing to
wear the criticism of a badge of honor
if it means
that my state has a state in which every
parent has a right to send their kid to
in-person instruction
everybody has a right to work and a
right to pursue
their vocations every business has a
right to operate
and we've done that we've trusted people
and as you mentioned
you know our coveted mortality is less
than the national average per capita
and on the vaccine front we were the
first state in the country to begin
vaccinating citizens
residents of long-term care facilities
and we were the first state in the
country
to start vaccinating our broader over 65
population
and so we're very proud of leading those
efforts and i think you're going to
continue to see a lot of good things
that
your guests before mentioned we're
partnering with supermarkets even and
really
uh papering us across the state so i'm
happy
for the criticism because you know what
i don't seek validation by the media
what i seek is supporting the citizens
of my state and i can tell you
as this pandemic is worn on the number
of times someone has come up to me
with tears in their eyes saying if it
wasn't for you my kid would not be in
school
and i would not have my job thank you
that is why i'm in this job
i mean just being honest here how many
huge department stores were burned down
in the state of florida during the blm
riots
how many cities do you have in florida
that are empty husks that are ghost
towns shells like say camden new jersey
or
five other cities in new jersey do you
have a lot of that in the state of
florida
no you know we are we're doing very well
um economically
uh obviously our tourism industry has
gotten hit that's recovering
home sales are up i think 22 percent
year over year
people have opportunities in florida
they're seeing that they're coming here
for greener pastures
and yes we take law and order very
seriously we want to protect our
citizens
safety and we're obviously not going to
tolerate a minneapolis type situation
when that was going on this summer
i had the national guard on standby we
were working with our localities in the
state of florida
and you didn't see there here what you
saw there
do you think you'd get fair treatment
from cnn
if your brother had a prime time show on
that channel
[Laughter]
well if if ifs and butts were candy and
nuts every day would be christmas but
you know i think it's pretty clear some
of these networks obviously
they have agendas they're they're doing
narratives
they're not trying to report facts
anymore it's all about spinning whatever
narrative they think can get ratings
and that's just the reality of the
situation so it doesn't impact me
we're going to continue keeping our eye
on the ball and working as hard as we
can to deliver results
i mean the truth is always in the
results it's not on what people say it's
and what they do so give us a snapshot
of the inflow into florida from other
states in this country recently
well i can tell you we weren't going to
have the for the final numbers for 2020
yet uh for for another few weeks
but if you look at new home bill new
home builds new home starts
if you look at home sales prices going
up
i mean it's pretty clear that people are
viewing florida as a landing pad
you know tucker it's interesting as this
went on i would encounter people
particularly in september
that would move from parts of the
country say look they closed our schools
i want your schools are open i'm going
to come here because you guys are doing
it right
so i think there's been a variety of
factors taxes has been one thing tucker
but i really do think these lockdowns
have driven some people to florida
who just had enough with these draconian
ineffective restrictions
they think you're going to be the
republican nominee that's why they're
attacking you
i'm not going to ask you to respond to
that i know it's an uncomfortable
observation but i think that's what's
really going on tucker i can tell you
i'm pretty confident i'll be the
governor nominee in 2022 here in florida
so
you know we look forward to running that
race good to see you tonight thank you
thanks